Speaker 1: All right. Let's get to a legal
opinion. Laurence Tribe, Harvard law professor,
thinks Trump should be working up an insanity
defense at a hypothetical trial. We're going
to talk about the difficulties of pleading
insanity. Business Insider Report Trump's
legal team better be able to get him to plead
insanity at trial. Harvard law professor says
a Harvard law professor suggested that Trump's
legal team should get him to plead insanity if he
does go on trial. In a tweet Sunday, the professor
Laurence Tribe, an expert on constitutional law,
commented on Trump's video message to the House
Select Committee on January six, 2021. If this
is the defense at Trump's forthcoming trial, I
don't envy the lawyers who agree to represent him,
Tribe tweeted. They'd better be psychiatrists,
expert at reflexive projection and capable of
getting their client to plead insanity. Now
we're going to look at Trump's statement to the
January six committee tomorrow in more detail. But
Trump attacks the committee members as being bad
people. He says there was no evidence he is just
a wacky, wacky, wacky guy. Now let's talk about an
insanity defense. Number one, it's important to
remember that an insanity plea is not a get out
of jail free card. It's a defense that wants to
mitigate the punishment for a crime by arguing the
defendant was not in control of their actions due
to mental illness. The defendant didn't understand
the consequences of their decisions due to mental
illness, which means that even if you success
succeed at defending someone on the basis of
insanity, you can still be found guilty and face
punishment, like being confined to a mental health
facility, for example. Now, I don't actually think
any of that's going to happen with Trump tomorrow.
We'll have Jamie Raskin's recent comments, what he
believes is going to happen to Trump that. But
that's a difficulty or something to understand,
I would say, about an insanity defense. One of
the biggest challenges in pleading insanity is
burden of proof, because in order to successfully
argue the defense of insanity, the defendant
must present evidence that they were suffering
from a mental illness at the time of the crime,
that that caused them to lack the capacity to
understand that their actions were wrong or
illegal or whatever the case may be. That is often
very difficult to do because the defendant needs
to provide detailed information about their mental
state and the symptoms they were experiencing.
They bring in medical experts. And it is a
it's difficult to meet that burden of proof,
particularly if Donald Trump is otherwise,
quote, functioning, although we would argue
he wasn't really functioning. It wasn't really
working, but functioning as president of the
United States. There's also the stigma that
surrounds mental illness because there are
many people who view mental illness. This is
a weakness or a character flaw rather than a
medical condition. So even in a case where the
defense actually can meet that burden of proof.
There are still jurors as a general
that people who may end up on the jury,
which might not be easily convinced that what
they were seeing were the out of control actions
of someone suffering from mental illness rather
than just somebody who broke the law. So insanity
defense is an uphill battle. If it's Trump, I
think it's a particularly uphill battle because of
the other circumstances I mentioned. In addition
to the difficulty of getting a jury that would be
neutral enough about Trump's actions, that they
would really give the insanity consideration,
the fair consideration that it would ideally
get in front of a jury. So I think it's a big
uphill battle and we may talk more about that
in the future, but that's Laurence Tribe's idea.